[Music]
so today I'm gonna do my best to answer
one of the toughest questions I get
asking and data is Pat can I live a
balanced life does it exist I get asked
that every single day and listen before
I get into all my points about the whole
argument I want to make for this on how
to think about it I want to make a point
you and here's what it is
when you say I want to live a balanced
life you forget that we are not machines
let me explain what I mean by this you
see a machine is a single-minded job
this here his job it's job is to light
up the room this camera's job is to
either take pictures or video record
this audio has a job of recording my
voice they usually don't have a million
different things they're thinking about
their single minded and they get the job
done they don't have a million other
things you and I were not machines and
when we're not machines our brain right
now think about the last five minutes
before you watch this video what have
you been thinking about all day today
let me give you a few times tell me if
any of them is yours you're thinking
about who won the game yesterday the
argument you got into with your wife
your husband your girlfriend your
boyfriend this morning you're still
texting going back and forth you're not
answering your call that 877 number you
got on your phone you're wondering if
it's a creditor that's trying to collect
money from you that ticket you got two
weeks ago you still haven't gotten the
mound you don't know how much the
speeding tickets gonna be if it's gonna
be over $200 and if you're gonna get
your license suspended you don't know
what you're gonna work out and I said
back shoulders am i doing arms I did
arms one did I do arms I don't know one
that I did arms you're wondering that
Facebook notification you just got right
now why did that personal friend me
I just posted a picture on Instagram why
has a Mary liked it if she's supposed to
like it she always likes it my mom is
upset at me Rana cuz I forgot to call
her on her birthday and I forgot to call
her on this other day my dad is upset my
brother and sisters are getting too far
what do I do you have so many things on
your mind and our mind wanders it drifts
so when it does that we can't be a
machine it's all over the place so to
live a balanced life that utopian
perfection balanced life doesn't exist
how
are there hacks out there for you to
figure out ways to try to do your best
to have a balanced life yes I'm gonna do
my best to explain it to here on what
things have worked for me and by the way
before I get into this if you haven't
subscribed to this channel click on the
subscribe button out a million subs when
we have a million subs we're gonna put
the first live value 10 min event to get
them 90 days later and if you have any
questions thoughts comments about what I
covered comment on the bottom so here's
here's why even a person starts thinking
about do I live a balanced life or not
and this is what it is the reason why we
think about it is because someone in
your life a spouse a mom a dad a brother
or sister a boss someone made you feel
guilty what do you mean somebody made me
feel guilty let me explain you could be
sitting there at a dinner table okay or
having a conversation with somebody and
someone says the following here's what
they say you know in order to have a
happy marriage you have to be home at
night at 6 o'clock every night and you
don't do that you just felt guilty your
spouse is sinner you're saying maybe I'm
not a good spouse maybe I'm not a good
husband maybe I'm not a good father you
just felt guilty you have another
situation somebody will say you know it
is not healthy to live an unbalanced
life again
you feel guilty maybe I'm not live in
healthy life maybe I'm not a good person
maybe I'm not doing the right way maybe
I'm supposed to be doing in a whole
different way here's another one they'll
say things like nothing matters more to
me than family listen Jon nothing in
your life should mean more to you than
your family right and what does that
state will really mean in the first
place think about it so nothing means
more to me than my family okay if
nothing means more to me that my family
why am i spending time on my job I
should be home with the kids I shouldn't
have a job I shouldn't do anything else
I should just be around my family
because nothing matters more to me to my
friend do you know that single statement
right there do you know how many people
get confused over that single statement
feel guilty over that statement nothing
should matter more to you than your
family so now somebody could say well it
is true Pat what's your argument look my
dad is 75 years old okay and I'm a
selfish human being I am I want my dad
in Texas with
my dad's in LA he lives in LA all his
friends his family everybody pretty much
is in LA in Texas he only has me right
selfishly I can pay him all the money in
the world to want to come a move to
Texas and I can say hey don't you love
your kids don't you love your grand can
make him feel guilty right I can do that
to him and make him feel guilty but
here's what happens
say if I move him over here he has
nothing to do so throughout the day he
has nothing to do all the stuff I come
home on the weekend and we spend time
together selfish right in LA he's still
a chemist he still does exciting jobs he
has a whole life of himself he has a
routine I got him a nice Mercedes he has
all this stuff to do on a daily basis
I'm robbing him of his life and his
routines if he comes with Alice so does
that mean he doesn't love his family and
nothing's more important to his family I
can take my dad all loves his family and
the example is sick but these comments
confuse people so Pat what is your point
here's here's my point by far the most
important thing that you have to answer
before talking about work-life balance
is you got to decide how clear you are
about your vision and the life you want
to live so Pat what are you talking
about let me explain so you may be
watching this if you follow value tame
and I think it's fair to say that you're
probably an aspiring entrepreneur or
you're an executive you're doing it for
yourself or you run a business but
you're trying to grow and get yourself
to the next level fair enough
you're trying to do that and I'm giving
you value and I'm sharing the mistakes
and the things that I've done that
hopefully give you some kind of
direction what to do with your life
great let's set that part aside if your
clarity on the vision and the life you
want to live is that clear you won't
feel guilty let me explain lowest level
of a vision could be somebody saying Pat
I want to figure out a way to make a
hundred 150 250 thousand dollars a year
that's what I want to do and I'm happy
once I get to that point no problem the
second one could be somebody is watching
and say Pat I want to be a
multimillionaire and be financially free
and that's my goal and guess what no
problem
somebody else could be watching it's
very few of you
some others could be watching a scene
honestly I can't do a lot with $250,000
your income and I can't do a lot just
being a millionaire I'm driven by
history I'm driven by doing something
big I want to change the world I want my
last name to be remembered I want to do
something significant that impacts the
world because I got so much flip and
fire in my belly I can't even describe
it okay whoever you are whether you're
the first one second one third one now
you're clear because here's what comes
after that if you're the first one after
you haven't a clear vision comes your
timeline pow what do you mean by
timeline here's what I mean by timeline
so timeline could be look I just want to
make 100 220 $50,000 your income your
timeline for being all out hard work
could be three to five years
that's your timeline second person says
god I want to be a millionaire your
timeline maybe you have to go all out
for five to ten years
the third one maybe somebody says Pat I
want to chase history that may be a 10
20 30 40 your type of a thing you got to
do so it ain't a short-term period thing
you got to do but now you have your
vision and you're clear on it and now
you have your timeline and then you're
clear on it so now regardless of what
level you're in for those of you guys
that ask me the other question which is
Pat do you think anybody can be an
entrepreneur and I give you the answer
which is what yes I believe anybody can
be an entrepreneur but there's a problem
there's a problem in that answer that is
not clear enough so let me clarify it
for you can anybody become an
entrepreneur yes it's everybody willing
to do the work to become an entrepreneur
absolutely not a lady told me one of the
best things she was talking about
raising kids and all this other stuff
she says she said Pat do you know what
is the closest pain you will ever go
through in your life of giving birth to
a child I said I don't know what it is
but what do you think it is this was a
50 year old lady she said the closest
thing you will ever experience is by you
starting a company being a start-up
entrepreneur building a business because
it's absolute painful annoying
challenging frustrating it's gonna suck
you're gonna have to make sacrifices you
will have mental
emotional breakdowns at some point it's
gonna be that painful and guess what
everybody wants to experience the
history and all that stuff but how many
people want to put up with that not a
lot of people not a lot of people so now
for those guys that are watching us and
we're Pat I'm still trying to be curious
what do you mean by work/life balance
what does this have to do with that
everything because you first got to go
back and figure out who you want to be
what life you want to live what is the
formula what is the sacrifice what is
the timeline I have so the correlation
between that once I get clear somebody
can't make you feel guilty you know why
because you already know what it's gonna
take you already know what your timeline
is you already know what life you want
to live you already know how big of a
life you want to build you're clear on
it it's crystal and you know your
timeline so I can't make you feel guilty
and I'm your brother-in-law I can't make
you feel guilty and I'm your dad or your
mom or your brother or your sister or
your boyfriend your girlfriend I can't
because you're clear make sense and no
one can make you feel guilty now let's
go to the next part the closest thing to
wanting to become a professional
entrepreneur is the following so again
I'm trying to make this argument you to
understand this before I go and give it
a tips on living a balanced life here's
the argument the closest thing to
becoming a professional entrepreneurs a
following an athlete professional
athletes think about the sacrifices they
make basketball players they play 82
games in a season not including pre
season or playoffs on the road they're
on the road six months out of the year
okay so think about you're gonna miss
moments you're gonna be doing stuff you
won't be sweet and sleeping in your bed
every night you're sleeping in a hotel
all these other things baseball is 162
games in season not including pre not
including playoffs you're playing for
eight months out of the year is what
you're doing right then the other
clothes thing to becoming an
entrepreneur is a musician why your
musician you're touring all the time
you're on the road all the time or a
general you're in the field you're on
war you're doing stuff you're in you're
have two constant go out there and doing
certain things right a Hollywood actor a
superstar in Hollywood Pat what do you
mean by Hollywood actor you know how
long it takes to shoot a movie three to
six months you're gone you're away you
could be in New Zealand shooting a video
and your family's back in town going to
school to private school and you're in
New Zealand skyping with them every day
that's the sacrifice at that level
another one could be a politician
campaigning hey I would love to be a
president one day do you really want to
campaign for 18 months every single day
and if you don't you're gonna lose to
another guy that is willing to campaign
every day do you really want to go
campaign and get rejected every day
people spit in your face they argue they
throw stuff at you and they say I can't
believe you believe in such-and-such I
cannot believe you think America should
have free health care I cannot believe
you think America shouldn't have free
health care no matter what philosophy
you think you have an opposition do you
really want to go through that because
that's what entrepreneurship I believe
you should own real estate half of
people say you shouldn't on real estate
I believe you should put your money in
stock market I don't believe in the
stock market you should embrace risk I
don't believe in real estate you should
buy technology stock I don't believe in
taking you should buy big I don't but
everything has an opposition and that's
painful for some people that's why
sometimes it's safer to go get a regular
job and say this is the route I'm gonna
take entrepreneurship is a pain in the
ass history demands a ton and all of
these journalists that are famous for
getting up and talking about balance
guess who they admire the most
unbalanced people in the world is who
they admire they admired the people who
are willing to go out and be unbalanced
they write about them all day long
journalists talk about the most
unbalanced human beings in the world
their obsession they have a job because
there are unbalanced people out there if
there were no unbalanced people out
there media and journalism wouldn't
exist because they need somebody to talk
smack about that's how they make their
money and who makes news to have people
to write about high achievers with that
being said I want to leave you with a
couple actionable items you can apply
right off the bat so you can hopefully
have a little bit more of a balanced
life at least so here's what the couple
things are one do you remember how
earlier I told the story of the
difference between machines and us human
beings is because we wander and we drift
and we think about things here's what I
want you to be thinking about the reason
why we wander and we drift why do we is
because we don't have a clear answer and
we're questioning the decision we're
about to make let me elaborate
you ever woken up in the morning
spending 17 minutes in your closet
wondering which jeans which suit which
tie which shirt to wear on would shoes
have you ever done that
tests that have wasted 22 minutes have
you ever gone on lunch and you're
wondering where to eat I'm gonna cheat
Portland I'm gonna go I'm gonna go over
here now let's go over here you know
what I don't know about this 32 minutes
was spent just deciding were to have
lunch here's a system very simple system
when it comes down to your mind
wandering and it's making a decision ask
yourself what's the level of priority on
this decision I need to make hello let's
just go right here cool I'm going I'm
not spending 22 minutes one minute we're
going right here if the mind goes and
it's saying well I'm wandering I'm
making it I don't really know if I'm
making the right decision if it's a very
very big decision guess what take your
time
because it's high priority so pause ask
yourself level a priority then take your
time on decision based on the level of
priority second thing I want you to be
thinking about remember how earlier I
talked to you about guilt so people make
you feel guilty you're working too hard
you're not spending enough time with
your family if you don't have dinner
right now with your family you're not a
good parent you're not a good husband
whatever all those things okay so here
is guilt if you are feeling guilty
write out your values and principles
that you want to live by and these
values and principles are gonna match
the life you want to live in the vision
you want to live when your values and
principles are committed to your vision
and the life you want to live here's
what's gonna happen there's going to be
a conflict and the conflict is some of
your current friends and family are not
gonna like your current value system and
they're gonna make you feel guilty
they're gonna say you know honestly
Patrick I just want you to know that you
ought to really be thinking about your
current schedule and what you're doing
at that thought that the guilt guilt
guilt guilt guilt I don't know if this
is the right thing you're doing see they
don't know your values and principle
matches the vision and the life you want
to live because you're clear and they're
not you can't judge them because they
don't know what your vision is now if
it's somebody that's very important to
you wife husband kids you know spouse
mom dad sit down explain to them here's
my values here's the principles I want
to live by this is the vision I am
clear the next three to five years I'm
gonna do this babe I want to go on a
5-10 run and I need you to support me
mom dad I'm going on a 1020 roll because
I want to do this for my life and expect
opposition expect laughter expect people
to say they're talking about your vision
what do you mean vision you've never
used the word vision before
what do you mean clarity I've never
heard you use the word clarity before
what do you talk about values in
principle you want to live by it doesn't
matter because you either have to
compromise your vision that you want to
live your life
the vision that's clear to you or you
have to compromise certain relationships
and when it says relationship you don't
need to compromise mom and dad brother
sister they don't have to fully believe
in it but some friends
you got a lot of them you can get rid of
I'm telling you right now you got a lot
of them that they no longer want the
life that you want them if you don't cut
it out they have so much influence on
your vision that you don't even know
they're gonna prevent you from having
some of your visions becoming a reality
become a reality so again back to it
system Lowepro a priority don't take a
lot of time high probability to take
your time to make the decision so when
you're wandering and drifting to you
feel guilty have your set of values and
principles match your vision you want to
live with the timeline and the sacrifice
you need to make then adjust with
certain friends you have then at that
point hopefully have fewer things that
you have to attend to in your life so at
least you can be a little bit more of a
balanced life that matches your vision
that you want to live again I hope this
made sense to you by the way if it was a
lot of things I have a free PDF for you
click on a link below go download the
PDF go through what I covered the notes
and maybe watch the video for a second
time so it covers certain things I said
that maybe it's not under PDF and you
can take some notes and if you got any
questions comments thoughts comment on
the bottom and if you haven't yet
subscribed to the channel click on the
subscribe button and join the
notification squad by clicking on the
alert button take everybody bye-bye